Speaker 1: Again, Texas is having a power
emergency and a power plant failure. And
what they're busy doing is sending migrants in
busses to Kamala Harris's house. Think of it
totally predictable. Newsweek reports. Greg Abbott
Faces Texas Grid Emergency As Power Plant Failed.
Power Plants Fail. Texas Governor Greg Abbott is
facing a grid emergency this holiday weekend. Do
it's like a repeat article. But you know, you
look at the date. It is Christmas Day, 2022.
An Arctic blast is causing failures at power
plants in the state. It's happening again. The
U.S. Department of Energy on Friday declared an
emergency in Texas, quote, due to a shortage of
electric energy, a shortage of facilities for the
generation of electric energy and other causes.
The department's emergency order allows Texas
grid operators to pollute more than allowed in
an effort to boost electricity generation
amid threatening cold temperatures. This
means Texas power plants can burn dirtier
fuel oil instead of natural gas to generate
power through Christmas morning. Extra
pollution folks served alongside Santa.
The Electric Reliability Council of Texas, known
as ERCOT, which serves 90% of the customers in
the state, requested the emergency order exceed
the usual federal air quality restrictions on
Friday. So I just want to remind people who
maybe don't remember or missed or weren't
paying attention when this previously happened.
Texas, because it is a bastion of freedom and
strength and alpha male energy and liberty.
And what words am I forgetting here? Freedom,
patriotism, all that stuff. They have decided to
essentially compartmentalize their electrical grid
so that when there is a shortage due to extremely
cold temperatures or extremely hot temperatures,
or for whatever reason, when there
is a shortage of electrical power,
they are not able to just draw from neighboring
grids and utilities the way almost all, if not
all of the rest of the United States is able to
do. Now, Texas did this because they're a big boy.
They're so strong. You're such a big boy,
Texas. And yet it fails almost every year,
it seems like. And as a result of the failure,
they end up polluting even more because they get
exemptions to how much pollution they can pump
into the atmosphere. Because after all, it's an
emergency. An emergency they cost so predictable
in that it's happening again. Secondly,
Texas spent Christmas sending migrants to Kamala
Harris's house on busses instead of dealing with
this to the extent that they'd even be able to
deal with it. So I feel for the people of Texas. I
do. This is an absolutely horrible thing. FEMA is
going to end up likely footing a big part of the
bill again in order to help people. And it's not
really accurate to call this a natural disaster.
What I mean by that is, yes, it is a weather event
that is the catalyst for this happening yet again.
But they decided to organize their electrical
grid like this. They have had years of time to
try to reorganize their electrical grid and
to actually connect it to neighboring grids
and they don't want to do it. And Greg Abbott is
at the top of the list of horrible people. He's,
you know, wasting money shipping immigrants
to the vice president's house while this is
going on in Texas. So this was predictable.
We know the solutions. We know the political
reasons why Texas has chosen to do this. And
as fortunately, many states are moving forward,
number of electric vehicles purchased as a
percentage of new cars is going up. Solar
capacity being installed is increasing retrofits
of homes to totally electric heat pump systems,
which can be powered by the sun solar. We've we're
seeing all these advancements in so many states.
Texas is saying we have an emergency we caused
for which we now want to be allowed to pump
extra pollution into the atmosphere. It's
quite literally what's taking place. It's
disgusting. AB Abbott's disgusting. We know what
the solution is. They don't want to do it. Texans
are increasingly sick of it but they really
don't seem willing to get rid of Greg Abbott
for it. I mean they had an option right when it
was Abbott versus Beto O'Rourke. We knew which
of the two supported changing this ERCOT fiasco
better and we know which of the two preferred to
defend the status quo. Greg Abbott Well they got
Abbott and it's happening again and I feel bad for
the people of Texas and also it might be time to
wake up and ask for something different and vote
for something different. Well, it's going to be a
few years now before they have that opportunity.
We'll see where this goes. We'll see how long it
lasts. Remember? Subscribe to the YouTube channel
at YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show. We
are pushing, pushing, pushing like a boulder up
a mountain towards 2 million YouTube subscribers.
Help get us one closer. The David Pakman Show is
a community supported program. You can support the
program by signing up at Joint Pack Mint.com. You
can use the coupon code. Please, no more Trump.
Please, no more Trump. Please, no more Trump.
You know it. Obama now. Yeah. To get a discount,
you'll get the daily bonus show, commercial free
audio and video streams of the show and all
of that great stuff at join Pacman dot com.